[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein Notruf auf der monterosa Hütte für
Bergretter Richard
Lener ich bin
auf zwei Bergsteiger sind
abgestürztier jetzt muss die
Rettungscrew aus zermat zu Hilfe kommen
bei windb von über 100 km pro
stundearke
schwierigeverhält Kontak die Opfer sind
schwer zu
erreichen hoch hinaus über Menschen und
ihre Leidenschaft in den Schweizer
Bergen
[Musik]
zwei Tage vorher auf der monterosa Hütte
mitten in den wallisser Alpen Richard
lena ist hier Hüttenwart Bergretter ist
sein Nebenjob jetzt in der Sommersaison
ist er fast immer hier
[Musik]
oben so der
tagf wenig Rü aber oder am Morgen früher
so Abend und morgen stimm sind immer
grandios
h ja in dieser Augustwoche hat er
zusätzlich pqu als
Bergretter er muss rund um die Uhr mit
einem Notruf rechnen dies trotz normalem
hüttenalltag ja das
Salat wie viel
Hef wie viel
Köpfe kannst
nehmen zusätzlich führt er auch noch ein
Hotel unten in zmat ist Bergführer und
hat eine Familie ich meine durch das
dass das ein ABS
parizittis me jetzt kan sageen rund im
Monat ist ja nachher oder in F Woche ST
da und nachher ich wieder ein anderer
Rythmus V dem her sie wir schon nicht
immer auf deine
100% es ist 10:3 die ersten Gäste
treffen
ein
ja
g ich mache mir bereit g
tschüss es geht auf für
eineation Berg ja
genau Wik oder sind oder Verhältnis
schwierig
[Musik]
s kan so minut bis der H
da ich bin auf
H
die alpinen Rettungen laufen im Wallis
über die erzerm die zentrale hat auch
den Bergretter
alarmiert Pilot ist Robert
[Musik]
Andenmatten zuerst muss sich das
Rettungsteam einen Überblick
verschaffen
[Musik]
die genaue Position der Bergsteiger ist
unklar unten am Fels Aufschwung sind die
Bergsteiger kurz sichtbar für die Crew
ist klar es braucht eine Rettung aus der
Luft
Richard len als bergspezialist wird an
die Seilwinde
[Musik]
angehängt und dann soll er zu ihnen
hinuntergelassen
werden die Bergsteiger sitzen auf einem
kleinen Felsvorsprung der Pilot muss
Richard len an der Absturzstelle
absetzen
läuft Richter der
Kur okay
[Musik]
me
der erste Teil hat geklappt beide
Bergsteiger sind unverletzt aber die
Frau hat
Magenprobleme Sie und Ihr Partner sind
früh am Morgen von der bordierhütte
ausgestartet die Frau erzählt sie habe
ein paar Stunden später Bauchschmerzen
bekommen dann Durchfall dann Erbrechen
jetzt sei sie zu schwach um
weiterzugehen
mach du sicherst D
da Patient
bereit du bleibst sitzen
ja die Frau wird als erste ausgeflogen
dann passiert etwas womit der rter nicht
gerechnet
[Musik]
hat die Frau hat Angst doch es muss
schnell
gehen bergsteigen ist das eine hunderte
Meter über dem Abgrund hängen etwas
anderes die Frau wird auf dem Gletscher
abgesetzt jetzt wird auch ihr
Kletterpartner
ausgeflogen da der Gerettete Steigeisen
trägt kann er nicht in den Hel hinein
und muss auf den Kufen bleiben Richard
Lener als Bergretter ist für die
Sicherheit der Personen
verantwortlich
ja urteile
wer wir
beurteileilot von Wind Person Z Personen
alles so Sache
während bespreche und nachher
[Musik]
umset die Frau kommt in ein Spital ihr
Begleiter wird ins Tal
geflogen erten ist die Bergung damit
abgeschlossen meistens nach
rückmeldig medizinisch Z das schon D
Informationen
sa das
ist sa sind was schlimmer sind dass das
nicht Kind
so Familie gler
nacher
und nach der
Großvater steich
und der Bub ist nachher verstorben ja
ma immer
schwierig
auf der Hütte sind unterdessen die
ersten Wanderer angekommen etwa 4
Stunden dauert der Aufstieg von der
gornergradbahn der wandereranteil in der
Hütte steigt stetig nicht alle haben
viel alpine
Erfahrung mal auf
Gletscher und W
gefunden
gut ja aber ja natürlich all
wir immer wir
Mark das LI
Imig wenn grunderfah kann man machen die
[Musik]
Fr
Richard Lener führt die Hütte zusammen
mit seinem Freund Kilian emer dieser
übernimmt wenn er als Bergretter
unterwegs
ist morgen früh gehen das wei
jetzt kin
Grupp
alle a Leute arbeiten auf der
Hütte
[Musik]
das ist das ist endlose Geschichte ist
das ABW J mal wenn der und geh schon
wiederch bis
ab es ist natür meine eine gr na
immer
und übernach das wird nachher fast F 20
Stunde Betrieb bis letzte im Bett
sind B schon wi schon wieder und
da L verlang die ganze Stunde den
ab zu seiner Arbeit als Hüttenwart
gehört es auch den Zustiegsweg durch das
gletscherlabyrint zu unterhalten am
Nachmittag kontrollieren Richard Lena
und Kilian emcker ob die Markierungen
versetzt werden
müssen
hier hier
ganze F
breitit W oben komum
SP jetzt ziemlich
veränder
W er
cm derer FL natür da Glitcher in
Richtung Weg sch das alles mit aber hier
Weg nach eigent quer durch geh
sch der
Weg immer wieder die ganze
stecke ist dass sie fast nicht mehr
passierbar ist Richard leener muss dafür
sorgen dass nicht plötzlich auf dem
gletscherweg Rettungen nötig
werden mindestens alle 10 Tage setzen
sie Wegmarkierungen neu als Orientierung
für die
Besucher die die die
schmelzen aber wenn es windet und Sturm
ist
geh ja soll tankke ja
ja hoppala
perfekt bittte schön bis
später jedes Jahr wird das Eis weniger
also hier wir war natürlich jeder Tag
auf dem Weg und der Weg m weg machen da
du jedes Jahr Riesenunterschied wie der
gletser zurück geht wie der gletcher
absinkt im alterwg wie von der Wand wie
viel Meter das das im J
enorm im
[Musik]
Moment es wird Abend fast alle Gäste
sind angekommen nur zwei fehlen noch ein
Sohn von Richard Lena und dessen
Kollege
hey cool ciao
grünse ja
aber
das ja
ja Nachmittag g kom jetzt kom mich und
ja m ja schaffen ja ja das
geh
los eig
ze und morgen
Abendessen müssen heute zuereitet
werden len hat früher die gandckhütte in
zermat
geführt dort ist sein Sohn Arno
aufgewachsen dieser weiß heute noch wo
und wie angepackt werden muss
[Musik]
jaü ich probiere
mal
super
Abend auf der monterosa Hütte Rettungen
gab es keine mehr
[Musik]
heute am nsten
die ersten Besucher verlassen die Hütte
Richard Leher hat bereits einen neuen
Einsatz die Information aus zermat
Wanderer wollen evakuiert
werden sie können anscheinend nicht mehr
[Musik]
weiter
Bergführer jetzt rechts sind links
die die vier wollen die Tour die so
genannte
Rut abbrechen und mit dem Helikopter
ausgeflogen
werden der Helikopter kommt steigst du
langsam
ein wie geht's gut vielen Dank müde ja
mental und
körperlich wir haben nicht viele Berge
in Brasilien
du bist aus
Brasilien auch solche taxiflüge gehören
zum
rettungsalltag 5 Minuten Heliflug nach
zermat einer stundenlangen
Wanderung sogenannte Blockierungen
Einsätze ohne dass ein medizinischer
Notfall vorliegt machen heute bis zu
einem Drittel der Rettungen
aus den vier Wanderern geht es gut aber
sie haben die Tour wohl
[Musik]
unterschätzt wir sind um 5 Uhr früh
losgewandert runter zum Gletscher wieder
hoch zum Berg D blanch wieder runter zum
nächsten Gletscher offenbar ist der
Originalweg nicht mehr
begehbar das wusstet ihr
nicht es war härter als wir erwartet
haben wir hätten nochmals weit hoch
müssen das wäre sehr anstrengend
geworden etwa 700 Franken pro Kopf wird
sie der rettungsfluh Kosten noch ist
unklar ob eine Versicherung diesen
Betrag übernehmen wird
wie geht's alles gut ja
danke es war der sicherste Weg zurück
und die beste Art die Tour abzuschließen
vielen
Dank wieder ein Einsatz abgeschlossen
nicht nur bei der erzermat sondern
schweizweit haben in den letzten Jahren
die Rettungen zugenommen das fällt auch
den beiden Bergrettern
auf die Gesellschaft ist schon sch
einfach also
schlich das ist
sotivation ke W um hilf B
git
hilft berüsichtung dass wir sich
oderle
aber das
ist Schutz
Schutz und sie als Retter gibt es
Momente in denen auch Sie daran denken
etw schief gehen könnte
W das
ist passiert bist eigent dass du und
dass machst und D das
Risikomanagement das B da nicht
[Musik]
wier selten hat Richard leener im Sommer
Zeit um mit seiner Familie etwas zu
unternehmen heute geht's auf eine BIK
Tour mit den beiden Söhnen Arno und
xav beide sind hier aufgewachsen und
machen eine Lehre im Dorf der eine bei
einem Zimmermann und der andere in einem
Hotel wegziehen käme für sie nicht in
Frage durch das D wir vor schon h sind
ganz immer
inpielt da beschäftigt der ganz Tag das
ist
super
ganzw aber
Spielplatz ganzes anderswachs wenn Du da
in der Berg und und mit Stein und mit
den wenige Sache eigentlich
D ein sommerlicher Kälteeinbruch auch
das gehört zum Leben in den
Bergen wen dann schne
Stein
ja
[Musik]
auf Bergtouren hat der Vater noch das
Kommando auf dem Bike sind die Söhne
Voraus mit dem bergretterjob des Vaters
ist die Familie
aufgewachsen probier wirklich nicht so
wie an die
Grenze
die Wim sind oder so das das sicher
immer B Hinterkopf
also nicht viel
mit ja S und jetzt interessiert sich
schon immer W was was passiert also ja
ob der schlimmer oder so ist und ja also
es ist einfach ein Teil wo
immer wen
isandich also ich schon Hal immer als
kleine Kinder cool gefunden
jalich schon immer da aber Papa macht
das sicher sehr sehr
gerfah
TEF sch wenn ir und meistens wenn fertig
ist geh tonim dass wir WIS und mit
Verfolg
Funk
ja sch Vertrauen ich kan sch wenn wenn
Sie unterwegs sind und jetzt so immer
mehr eig selbständig unterwegs sind ich
weiß natürlich die ganzefahre wo
unterwegs sind und ich weiß was kan
passieren durch das dass sie natür viel
R
Gemach den rettungsjob aufgrund der
Familie aufgeben das war kein
[Musik]
Thema
am nächsten Tag ist Richard Lena in der
Hütte bereits um 12:30 Uhr morgens auf
den Beinen Frühstück für die
Bergsteiger aber ich nach
NO das
ist
we auf D und mach das jetzt
nicht
ge glaube das macht niemand wirklich ger
die er und Kilian wechseln sich mit den
morgenschichten ab so dass der Tag für
die Angestellten nicht zu lange
wird wie jeden Tag checkt er am Morgen
früh das
Wetter nach kommen W so sch oder so
immer gewisse Unsicherheit da und ich
gerade so wenn ich wenn ich selber min
mein zum Wetter und Wind so vi 50 6 also
n ziemlich stark eigentlich das
grundsätzlich eigent machen wenn ich
weiß dass die bcke oder so dass ich weiß
was sind Sache W nicht mit Sache das das
nach
bereit
morgen wie
geht's scheint geschneit zu haben ja ein
bisschen ne Schnee schneit noch ganz
leicht ja mal gucken wie der so ist ja
aber erstmal geht's gut erstmal geht's
gut das ist die Hauptsache ist alles
bereit normalerweise sind die
Bergsteiger zu zweit unterwegs dieser
geht heute jedoch alleine los was W dein
Plan für heute ich gehe auf die
duferspitze schne
mal gucken wie weit ich
komme die dfpitze ist der höchste Berg
der Schweiz also
gest
Partner meine grundsätzlich dass
dasfenswert ist aber das
sindwachs zurück ich
die also sicher hier in das sind ke
ber machen eig all ir Glitcher
technische Sache oder so Dr sind das ist
also wirklich nicht
ZF gestern schon hat er den ersten Teil
der Route über einen Gletscher
ausgekundschaftet und fühlt sich gut
vorbereitet jetzt ist noch mal 1 cm
Neuschnee aber das ändert jetzt an der
spaltensituation nichts ich bin durch
den Eisbruch gegangen das ist eigentlich
schon das gefährlichstem wenn man das
kann das ist and auch nicht mehr schön
aber ich habe halt also eine Notruf App
habe ich mit auf dem Handy die
funktioniert soeit irgendwie Empfang da
ist ich habe dem hütenwort Bescheid
gesagt W ich wieren ja so also also ich
ich minimere schon das
Risiko und ich bin auch schon 20 Jahre
dabei
gegen 2:30 Uhr starten die
Seilschaften trotz kalten und
stürmischen Bedingungen die vorausgesagt
sind und das
anfangsaugust vhore
bis alles eigentlich alles alles zu ob
so
schlechtach Winter ob
durch also
zwischenri nicht jeder Tag MS es
nichtmer hab so zwischenri MS schon
sagen W morgen
los ich schon schön ja und
andere ich zurück
Stund
schon im Verlauf des Morgens
böhenspitzen bis zu 100
stundenkilomet dann um 10:30 Uhr ein
Notruf recht V
dir im Pol jemand der Stu
abkit Absturz und
itierumst an Bord Pilot Gerold Biener
und ein zweiter
Retter ist auf der Rückseite der
eisbedeckten Kuppe in der Südostwand des
polluxs am
zwillingsjoch zwei Bergsteiger seien
abseits der normalen Route unterwegs
[Applaus]
gewesen noch hat die Crew die Opfer
nicht
[Musik]
entdeckt
s sehr starke schwierige
Windverhältnisse der rettungskollege und
Richard Lener steigen aus um sich an
Seil anzuhängen und in die Nähe der
Unfallstelle geflogen zu
werden
Kontakt der Heli setzt sie auf dem
gipfelgrad des polluxs ab wo auch andere
Bergsteiger unterwegs
sind
irgendwo da unten im Geröll muss das
Opfer
liegen die Retter versuchen die
Unfallstelle zu Fuß zu erreichen sie
wissen nicht in welchem Zustand das
Opfer
ist
reagier
am heliandeplatz der monterosa Hütte
wartet Arzt Michael Krappitz auf seinen
Einsatz jetzt muss wir erstmal zum
Patient überhaupt hinkommen erstmal
gucken wie man da Gelände zurecht kommt
und wie die Verhältnisse sind und
dann käme ich ins
Spiel am Pollux haben unterdessen die
beiden Retter das Opfer
erreicht hat einen Felsblock ausgerissen
und ist
abgestürzt der erste hat den zweiten
mitgerissen sie stürzen etwa 60 m ab
einer ist schwer verletzt zwei
Bergführer sind bei
ihm wie geht es Dir ich bin von der
Bergrettung ist
passier ST auch sein
Partner dir geht's gut alles
gut der
dokt das Opfer blutet stark am
Kopf bleib bei
uns aber die hatten ja ein riesen
Schwein dass die nicht noch bis runter
sind aber er hat richtig gehalten er hat
gehalten schon schon
drüber unten auf der monterosa Hütte hat
sich der Arzt inzwischen an einer 100 m
langen Leine eingehängt und wird von
Pilot Gerold Biener zur Absturzstelle
geflogen der Pilot benötigt diese Länge
um mit dem Heli über der gradkante
schweben zu
können alles klar bei
dir ja alles klar gut wir gehen jetzt
hier vorne fortenbergr und dann sinken
wir dann hinten wieder ab so sollte ich
die Höhe haben ungefähr von diesem
Buckel hinten so bist du sicher über dem
hinteren Buckel ist das okay ja
positiv eine Person an einer so langen
Leine bei Wind von 100 stundenkilomet
Meter genau in einer Wand absetzen für
alle eine
Herausforderung Gerold Biener sieht den
Arzt nicht mehr genau er braucht die
Höhe per Funk okay mich wie hoch bist
duund musst mir die Höhe geben alle 5
Sekunden
[Musik]
bitte unter
mir
es hat geklappt der Arzt ist beim
Patienten ich bin der Arzt ich gebe dir
jetzt ein Schmerzmittel das auch müde
macht jetzt müssen sie den Patienten in
die Vakuummatratze
heben ja so
gut machen wir mal zu dass er ein
bisschen warm
kriegt der Wind ist inzwischen so stark
dass die Leine bei der monterosa Hütte
von 100 auf 130 m verlängert werden muss
damit der Patient sicher ausgeflogen
werden kann wenn wir schweinhe wir
wirklich der Doktor
bler der patientol aber das ist
natürlich in dem Wind mit so alleine das
ist nicht so
lustig
die italienischen Kollegen hatten zuvor
die Rettung aufgegeben Gerold Bina will
es trotzdem
versuchen inzwischen dauert die Rettung
schon fast Z
Stunden
[Musik]
Kontakt zte wird nun mit dem Arzt zu
einer tiefer gelegenen Hütte geflogen
von dort bringen ihn die italienischen
Kollegen ins Spital nach
Aosta jetzt müssen noch der zweite
verletzte und die Retter geholt werden
doch der Wind hat weiter
zugenommen 4
me
zuwiig zweite man am Bein verletzt
trotzdem muss zu Fuß
runter
[Musik]
bei der monterosa Hütte trifft
inzwischen der einzelne Bergsteiger ein
der am Morgen zur düfurspitze
aufgebrochen
ist hey wie war's
kalt hast du es geschafft ja ich war
oben
aber nichts aber ich war oben und es war
Sturm
es war richtig kalt es hat alles
gefroren aber du bist heil wieder
runtergekommen ich habe keine
Schramme alles gut
gegangen weit unten auf 2000 m nimmt
unterdessen der italienische
Rettungshelikopter den zweiten
Verletzten in Empfang für Richard Lena
als rettungsspezialisten geht ein langer
Tag zu Ende
[Musik]
so das ist
einfach alles alles erledigt tip to
super ja dir
[Musik]
über 5 Stunden war Richard Lener
unterwegs morgen
gessen
ja
ist
ganz
einfach sehr sehr sehr sehr sehrpruch
vol
Wind zwis 8 100 K
und Griss und das ganz gefährlich das
wenn du in der Bereich W noch Abwind
herrscht D magch der Helikopter nichtmer
der Unfallort ist so
saublöd darf einfach kein Fehler machen
de
[Musik]
Situation auf 30 bis 40 bergeinsätze
kommt Richard Lena als Retter pro Jahr
das war einer der
anspruchsvolleren er ist froh dass es
mit der helikopterrettung geklappt hat
zu Fuß sogenannt terrestrisch hätte die
Bergung bis in die Nacht
[Musik]
hineinedauert sicher ir wenn mit der
Temperatur mit dem storwi und allem W
halt irg
wen mit W D no wirklich
bringt von den Geretteten hören die
Retter selten ein Dankes
Wort auch in diesem
Fall wird der dar machen und nach
ichig de g wir s s die wir das als so
gut wie möglich erledige und nachher
gibt das schon gewisse Befriedigung wenn
wir es g gemacht hab also sicher Team
oder so wenn wir mehrere unterwegs S und
irgendes
wo R gemacht sagen okay das die L h
jetzt ohne das nier überlbt das git
schon Geiss
Befriedigung